so uh we have uh andrew chiles who is
the
uh he's the co-director he's uh from the
university of uh maryland he's the
co-director of the
joint center for
quantum influencers
between
university of maryland and nist
so
andrew is in is is an expert at quantum
algorithms and
you know
as well as
he's done this extensive work on the
simulation of quantum systems you know
uh
quantum um
um you know hamiltonian simulations so
welcome andrew uh with mike marcus
greiner who is um who's a professor at
uh at harvard as well
and um he's he's an experimentalist who
who works
extensively on on quantum simulation
um
using uh
uh with both einstein condensates as
well as ultra cooled fermi gases
um he is he was a
macarthur fellow and he's uh he's also
uh
involved in this
um this work on
observing quantum phase transitions from
superfluid to to martins to later in the
both habit systems
then we have two uh
sort of
young stars in the field there's monica
adelsberger from the university of
munich
welcome and
so she um
she works on again on quantum simulation
with ultra called pattern gases and
optical lattices um monica
you know is uh the winner of many
various prices the alfred nook prize and
the cloak wilhelm science award so
and then norman yao great to have you
here
norm is my colleague at berkeley in
physics
he's he's a protege of
misha luken and like misha he's
making his transition from
being a pure theorist to being both a
theorist and an experimentalist
and uh
norm of course
you know he's he's he's been a
miller fellow here at berkeley and uh
um uh you know with packet fellowship
etc but most recently he won the george
valley prize
for his work on non-equilibrium phases
of matter so welcome everybody and um
let me just uh say you know let's let's
start with um with uh
you know the
um
with a few minutes for each panelist
just to give your
you know your comments about misha's
talk
but also um you know
uh also about the prospects for for uh
you know for this sort of uh
you know the the scalability of uh
of of these of these systems and also uh
um you know into into the future both
uh and as well as um as well as a
comparison of uh you know uh of uh of
some of these um of of the kind of uh
platform that misha spoke about you know
what are its advantages and you know
where do you how do you compare it to
other platforms
so um
if we can
um and and of course
and of course also as a you know
comments on the on the actual
algorithmic aspects of the of what uh
misha spoke about so
possibly uh
um who would like to go first maybe
andrew would you like to speak about the
algorithmic aspect yeah
yeah no problem yeah i mean i thought it
was a beautiful talk and uh you know a
really impressive system and i think it
was you know really really uh you know
interesting to hear about about um the
things that have been going on
uh you know misha in your lab um yeah i
mean i thought it would be interesting
you know maybe to talk a little bit
about sort of um
the interaction between sort of what's
being done in these systems and sort of
computational ideas
um
uh you know i guess sometimes maybe the
the line between sort of an analog an
analog quantum simulation
and a physics experiment is a little bit
blurry um you know i guess we we heard
uh sometimes about sort of you know
realizing certain phases in the quantum
simulator but of course you know
realizing a quantum phase i guess is
something we don't we don't expect a
classical computer to do but maybe it
could answer you know computational
questions about um quantum phases
depending upon what the question is that
we want to look at so um yeah i mean i
think it would be interesting to maybe
talk a little bit in the panel and i'd
definitely like to hear you know what
misha and everyone has to say about this
um
uh sort of making links between what's
going on in in these kinds of quantum
simulation experiments and you know cs
theory um
so you know what are the sort of
computational questions that we can try
to address with simulators
you know certainly the dynamics of the
kinds of systems that you're realizing
are are classically hard in some sense
but um you know what are the kinds of
questions we would like to answer i
guess we can ask questions about like um
you know measuring correlation functions
in the ground states of these systems or
you know maybe trying to identify like
where is the value of some parameter in
the hamiltonian at which a phase
transition occurs i guess maybe those
are the kinds of questions one could
answer but i guess you know it would be
helpful for me as a person who wants to
think about algorithms to know sort of
what you think about you know the um the
interesting questions to ask about these
systems that we can phrase as kind of
crisp computational questions where we
can try to compare what we can do in
these in these quantum systems um and
and you know what we could maybe try to
do with classical computers but but
maybe you could argue would be hard um
and and i think also it would be
interesting to think about sort of like
um places where a computational
perspective maybe could help guide
what's going on in experiments you know
like um i guess you talked about sort of
you know for for realizing fault
tolerance the need to maybe develop new
ideas about how we would do that to make
fault tolerance more uh realizable but i
guess um you know it seems like maybe
there's an opportunity to develop new
theoretical tools that could help us
understand um what are the capabilities
of analog simulators you know how we
make them robust how we understand when
their output is correct
um so i think it would be interesting to
look for places where where maybe um
you know
sort of cs theory perspective could help
to address those kinds of questions
okay maybe i'll stop there
that's great yeah
thanks uh andrew so um i don't know how
you'd like to do this misha would you
like to speak to these or should we just
go through all the panelists and then
and come back to you
i think we should just go around that
spot okay okay great
so
uh who would like to
to go next uh
um
i'm happy to i can go
yeah okay great
um yeah so maybe i'll try to mention
kind of four questions that i think
might be sort of fun for the panel to
sort of discuss together with misha
um i think i mean again i mean the talk
was i think umesh put it very well
i think one is irrationally excited
about so many aspects of the talk i mean
it's just really exciting progress on so
many fronts
but maybe just a couple that
um misha emphasized and i want to sort
of mention as directions that one can
think about so one thing that misha
emphasized near the beginning of his
talk is this idea that there exists
maybe physical mechanisms like the
blockade which from a microscopic
perspective are more robust you know to
certain things for example to the motion
of the atoms to a little bit of extra
jitter here and there and one can ask an
interesting question in my opinion which
is
do there exist you know a class of you
know interactions that happen in nature
like the blockade
where one can naturally get robustness
to certain types of
error noise fluctuations that exist
within experimental platforms
and does that robustness maybe at a
fundamental level mean that those you
know making gates in sort of a long-term
digital vision does that mean that one
should expect that those types of
microscopic you know interactions will
enable just better gait fidelities you
know at a fundamental limit
and there i think it'd be really
interesting to hear monica and marcus's
perspective eventually on the balance
between you know things like blockade
based gates versus other neutral atom
based ideas for implementing gates in
for example optical lattices
is there some complementarity are there
some intrinsic advantages that one sees
in one versus the other
another thing that we should mention in
the middle of his talk and or maybe
something that combines you know the two
pieces of misha's talk and also you know
kind of pays tribute to what andrew was
talking about
is
you know what misha showed us in the
topological spin liquid section is that
in some sense the experiment was
performing surprisingly good you know
surprisingly better than maybe one would
naively expect from a theoretical phase
diagram perspective and that's very
special to me
so i wonder you know there's this
classic idea of encoding solutions
of really hard problems in ground states
and then trying to adiabatically prepare
such ground states
but usually as theorists were taught
that you know
for most of the really hard problems
there are prohibitive challenges in
terms of the way gaps close first
orderness of the transition
but is it possible that the experiment
is kind of telling us that you know one
should be a little bit more bold and
cavalier and maybe one doesn't
necessarily directly try to prepare into
the phase but even looks at nearby
phases where there can be a metastable
solution nearby which one could sort of
adiabatically get into and get stuck in
and that maybe kind of combines these
two aspects
um one last thing i wanted to mention is
sort of the last thing that that misha
did talk about as well in the outlook
which is this possibility of sort of
moving things around dynamically which
also seems extremely special to me
and there i think you know it'd be
interesting to hear per view from you
know umesh and others who are super
involved you know in these you know
foundational ideas of how one could
demonstrate things like quantum
advantage in an interactive fashion
because i think in principle what
misha's demonstrating is the possibility
of actually
moving things around and now performing
intermediate measurements
and then moving things back in kind of a
non-destructive way that allows
entanglement between the other degrees
of freedom to be maintained and i do
think that there's both science there at
the level of things that adam nahum and
many others are thinking about with
measurement based phase transitions but
also you know some interesting interplay
with quantum advantage protocols that
people like umesh and thomavidic have
thought about quite a bit so certainly
that would be something i'd love to hear
about
great thanks norm that's a lot to cheer
on maybe uh
monika or marcus who would
yeah but maybe i could uh
i
could talk real quick um
uh just about um
it's really exciting to see so um how
the quantum simulation in the nisk era
kind of
how they give us possibilities already
to
um address really hard questions and
study things that are really uh hard uh
to compute let me maybe give a little
overview of these um
of these atom platforms workforce so as
you know
um um i know one uh famous example for
quantum simulation is
poisoning atoms in optical lattices
right like like the superfluid mod that
you already mentioned um um there's
still a lot of development in that field
for example uh you can
make more programmable systems also
um measure things like integrity entropy
um many body purity all kind of um
things like that and if you're talking
about quantum advantage of course for
bosons you really want to go to
non-equilibrium situations and
as a for example uh
um
studies of of nbl
um
economization things like that um
it's quite amazing if you have more than
20 30 atoms and do dynamics over many
tunneling times and we have seen
coherence times of hundreds many hundred
tunneling times you get a pretty large
quantum volume there
um so that's boson's a fairly active
field also with gauge fields
as monique will
probably also mention
and then um um
right so as you
all know the second platform
like whitberg
adam said misha was uh talking about um
um has some similarities but it's
actually even more programmable and as
you mentioned we're working on really um
addressing
all the items individually to
have a very wide
programmability there
it's also a bit simpler and faster and
that high repetition rate actually makes
a big difference
um but i do want to mention and one
other platform real quick which is quite
special and i think there are many open
interesting questions and
it's not really quite understood yet how
to really think about these systems from
a quantum information point of view um
and that is fermionic atoms so as you
know if you put fermionic atoms into
optical lattices you realize the fermi
hybrid model which is really famous
powerful fundamental model in condensed
metaphysics and it's deceivingly simple
you can write it in half a line but um
but even but but it's really hard to
understand what the physics is and of
course you can as you change parameters
you had yet completely different
situations and uh
it's fascinating to me how difficult
like how can it be that such a simple
model has so much richness
and is so hard
to compute and so this is one very
active um
field in many groups
for example we've seen interferomagnetic
phases
and
i studied the doped harvard model uh
we've observed
like string patterns for example or
polar ones directly so that you can
really see this intricate interplay
between charge and spin degrees of
freedoms
um a lot of these experiments you know
we may be able to argue maybe this is
already in some kind of quantum
advantage regime uh certainly is not
possible to to compute these
things
but to me it's more important you know
is it really useful um and there i am
i'm really excited of the prospects um
for example we are in the middle of a
major upgrade to
to lower
temperatures to even much lower
temperatures and have a much wider class
of models you can program for example
all kind of different letter structures
um and things like that and so there
is a lot of exciting things to come
um from a
kind of confirmation point of view it's
fascinating to me how can it be that
such a simple model is so hard and what
does that mean and maybe
i just want to give that message to to
inspire some theorists maybe also
like how do you understand these these
these fermionic models from a quantum
formation
uh
um and theory point of view of course as
you know um
um a quantum system or fermion maps onto
a bosonic or spin model via the wigner
transform but the amazing thing is that
you can have a totally local fermionic
model that maps onto a highly non-local
spin or boozer problems
scalable quantum machines of course are
local
so if i implement the fermionic degree
of freedom
um
natively on such a machine then this
local model
studies models that would map on highly
non-local uh spin or
orbosa uh problems and so to me um that
seems an interesting question if
if
if there's maybe some important power
that lies in that
kind of um
in that mapping
yeah and just uh to wrap
uh this up so it um it's kind of funny
sometimes it's
you know a bit overwhelming
what the challenges are it feels a bit
hyped sometimes or you know is it will
it be hard to control an exponentially
large hilbert space um and so on but
then
um on those days if i then go into the
lab and i see that you know we can
really use a handful of atoms and these
atoms following very simple rules are
doing things that no supercomputer can
compute um that is certainly very
motivating and so this is a really
exciting time for quantum simulation to
really um
explore these kind of questions
great
thanks thanks marcus monica you've been
waiting patiently so
i'd love to hear what your problem uh
thanks for for having me in in this
distinguished panel
so um yeah i just add a little bit so
many many things have already been set
so i will just add a few more ideas um
without actually taking too much time
and i want to pick up a few ideas that
have been already mentioned in
particular
that analog
simulations have already been very
successful and it is very interesting of
course to think of
possible ways to answer interesting
questions in order to use this um to
demonstrate some quantum advantage and
it seems to me that indeed this
non-equilibrium phenomena or quench
dynamics can be one way and i think what
i have in mind there is that
this interplay of trying to understand
our quantum many body systems better and
better like now as was mentioned also in
the talk that we can reach 200 300 400
atoms
um we can also try to devise new more
efficient algorithms which maybe we can
use to describe the dynamics which
previously
were hard to develop just because we
don't have a very good handle on
estimating the error of certain
approximations that we make so there can
be i think an interesting interplay
between
the experiments the analog simulations
and the theory on the other hand in
order to learn more from a quantum
information point of view about what
degrees of freedom of the quantum
anybody system are relevant for this for
the dynamics that we are seeing and i
think maybe this also ties in a little
bit with the
idea of using fermions so maybe
um as part of this
one could think of developing hybrid
approaches where if we um
are able to control fermions very well
let's say in the lattice that we can
run parts of the algorithm on a quantum
machine where we i don't know eliminate
the sign problem let's say because we
can use the fermions and the lattice
very efficiently and combine it with
some classical algorithm in order to
solve
problems more efficiently
and this also
comes to one of the questions i would
like to pose to everybody
so i think the idea of using fermions is
very appealing in our type of platforms
and um it is an interesting question
a question um to answer if fermions can
be a way to reach quantum advantage for
certain models faster if you think of
simulating lattice gauge theories where
gauge fields are coupled to fermionic
matter
of course there are certain mappings on
to other models simpler models we can
integrate out fermionic degrees of
freedom in order to describe these
models but eventually i i would like to
understand if if maybe
fermions are more efficient in solving
some of these some of these questions
and then
going a little bit away from the analog
simulation towards the digital approach
um i also would like to pick up the idea
of developing
the platform so trying to understand
what are the the current limitations can
maybe
dynamically reconfigurable atoms in a
normal optical lattice using collisional
gates and
in in contrast to rudberg excitations
let's say
um be better like can we reach higher
fidelities if we use that should we
maybe think of different types of gates
should we rather make use of multi-qubit
gates in order to develop maybe more
resource efficient algorithms and
protocols where we can work with fewer
atoms and then maybe we don't need as
high fidelities
and then the other question would be
about
um well crosstalk but it's a bit less
important about error mitigation so we
have
talked about fault tolerant quantum
computation but then okay there are
several ideas out there but it seems to
me that
for now of course all of our platforms
have very different limitations in terms
of fidelities and the
fault tolerance schemes may not be
suited to protect us against the errors
that we have in the in the experiments
so against atom loss against
um spontaneous emission dephasing and so
on so i think this is another
interesting question to to explore
okay thanks thanks monica so there's a
lot uh
um misha for you to chew on there and
respond to can i add one more piece to
it you know i'll ask a very naive
question which uh
which you can just just uh bat away very
quickly and then get on to the meat of
these questions so so there were there
was this um you know
great robustness of this um of the red
redbuck blockade
so given that uh you know why uh given
that you have such a such a robust uh
mechanism underlying your interactions
so
what is you know why uh
what is the bottleneck on the fidelities
you know
as you know
knively i'm just thinking well if it's a
robust interaction shouldn't the
finalities be larger
yeah so yeah this okay you know there
are no simple questions to mesh so it's
you know it can itself you know take
you know
a couple of hour discussions but you
know but basically
when i mean that it's that this
interaction is robust what i mean by
that
for example is that it's relatively
insensitive to things like motion so for
example in most of our experiments we
don't cool atoms to the ground state
you know and uh
and you know they are not sensitive to
exact position for example if there is
position fluctuation
but of course there are other um
[Music]
contributions
um
so for example the redwork states
have a finite lifetime
and this lifetime is relatively long
it's you know it's you can be a couple
of hundred of microseconds
but it is you know it contributes to
you know finite uh
fidelity so another
um contribution is connected to
basically things like you know light
shifts that you basically are predator
kind of
energy level shifts in use by by laser
beams you know so all of these things at
the end kind of add up and you know i
think
we understand we believe they understand
the leading mechanisms but you know of
course you sort of solve the first order
mechanisms and then there will be other
mechanisms right
and um i think it is kind of
uh
interesting to actually compare since
the you know
uh marcus and monique
you know brought up the kind of
the idea so for example using atoms in
the ground states like basically
collisional interactions
and you know the quantum gates between
atoms with collisional interactions have
been demonstrated you know with
very
quite reasonable fidelity so
and you know it's interesting to compare
this these approaches so i would say the
kind of
i mean the the opportunities offered by
this bosonic and fermionic statistics
are very special
uh and you know in our case you know we
don't you know like we do everything so
fast that you know there is a lot of
motion is frozen you know we just can
implement spin models
uh so in that sense you know it's kind
of not as rich a system
but i would say there are maybe three
things which make this kind of recent
developments with this reebok arrays
uh kind of special one of them is that
these experiments are just very fast and
much faster than compare you know
than comparable you know like
experiments based on bc
and you know i think you know this is
not you know i think there's an
interesting challenge for let's say for
optical lens simulators to speed them up
and i think there are some ideas i know
in marcus's group how how to do it but
you know that's kind of when you enable
these experiments run at the highest
trap rate it kind of improves greatly
include that it improves the quality of
life of junior scientists in the lab you
know the second and the second thing is
that you know the interactions between
the three burg atoms are very strong and
so as a result they are very forgiving
too many of the
you know
things so basically if your interaction
at the kilohertz level then you have to
work very very hard to just you know
even if atoms are well isolated you know
to basically if you want to you know
look at like third or fourth digits
infidelity and you know i think the
other um the other thing is that you
know at least kind of relatively
speaking this
arrays are probably at the moment a bit
more programmable compared to
to
uh to optical efficacies then again
there are some opportunities where i
think these other experiments you know
can can be pushed forward you know so
this is basically you know this is not
you know there's a multi-dimensional
parameter space right
and you know i think there are you know
in some and it's for sure it's kind of
you know to if you have you know a
fermionic degree of freedom it's much
better to directly implement it in a
in in analog way you know
as opposed to
just try to simulate it through through
qubits you know which is extremely
costly so
but you know one thing i should kind of
maybe moving on to some of the other
things which was kind of touched upon
so there is no question that quantum
dynamics
is probably the kind of the most obvious
kind of first frontier
where you know you know like we can
really use these systems you know you
can call them
experiments simulators computers but you
know this is an area where basically
you know you kind of you basically go to
like you know to the corners of hilbert
space where no one has ever been
and you know in with this kind of
methods
you know if you go there you bound to
make discoveries and it's certainly in
our work whenever we tried
you know some kind of like you know
something even mildly non-equilibrium we
would always discover something new you
know so we talked about this you know
spin liquid being a kind of meta stable
state which indeed kind of opens up an
intriguing prospect so there might be
much larger sets of hamiltonians which
you feel prepared state will protect it
you know it doesn't have to be you know
a ground state a lot of things around us
are very stable a piece of diamond right
you know it's you know as an example
right you know so
um but that but maybe the thing which
actually i would kind of
connecting to andrew's uh
kind of excellent points you know the
kind of maybe the interesting kind of
theoretical kind of
conceptual challenge is how we sort of
you know
like at this dynamics you know problems
you often create this kind of messy
entangled states you know
what do we look at you know what kind of
absorbables you know should we look at
how we know that our simulators are
working well you know
and um
i think you know
you know for example the opportunity
i think the quite special opportunity is
also along the line that monica
mentioned you know this kind of
opportunity where you will combine for
example analog simulators with some
digital circuits
you know where you can for example look
at things like you know entanglement
entropy kind of similar to marcus's
experiments few years ago
but also look at things like
entanglement spectrum i think they are
all now within the reach
in this topological observables where
you can maybe use some ancillars to sort
of probe some non-local you know degrees
of freedom you know all of these things
you know all of these are you know kind
of opportunities right
and so some of these observables are
extremely non-trivial and i think kind
of developing methods to kind of
interrogate these systems i think is
very very interesting challenge
so
uh
on a kind of on a on the other side you
know
like kind of connecting to try to
connect these things to computer science
i
i think one could also think about new
ways to implement um
quantum algorithms and you know the
brief discussion that i had about this
you know basically about solving this
maximum independent set you know was an
example of that you know
uh so
and you know you could say well okay so
you sort of worked very hard and we just
showed quadratic speed up but okay i
mean this is sort of
that's a point where we try to at least
chip away at kind of of this you know
basically you know can we find how can
we find you know next shores algorithm
right you know
there are some instances which will be
amendable to the speed up which are
you know which is substantial you know
and i think that's where you know basic
and like in at least in the near term we
have to use some kind of co-design we
have to use this efficient qubit
encoding otherwise we just don't have a
a chance to really explore this you know
you know these algorithms and kind of
you know they all the the kind of
meaningful explorations would require
you know hundreds of qubits and large
circuit depth so i think we have to be
kind of you know very creative in terms
of how we map you know the kind of
interesting computational classical
computational problems
two quantum algorithms and then to this
kind of hardware platforms but i think
there is a very very special opportunity
to kind of uh
to explore this this this kind of things
so
so
uh
[Music]
yeah so i guess i mentioned you know uh
okay yeah kind of
yeah a few things i mean in connection
to norms
um uh
points here
yeah i do think that you know thinking
about mechanisms such as blockade you
know which could enable robust entry i
think this is would be very very
interesting and useful and also
you know kind of extending them to
things like multi-qubit gates they can
you know provide very very powerful
right of course you need a certain
degree of non-locality then but you know
i think we have it you know in some of
the systems
so i also completely agree about sort of
opportunity of
going beyond the ground state physics
you know for example
you know can we prepare
you know some error correcting code
states we should then protect even if
they are not the ground states of the
hamiltonian and maybe interrogate
you know manage you know
combine this you know hamiltonian
protection with some kind of you know
anyone you know
um
kind of pairing mechanisms i think these
are all you know these are the things in
our attend i think we would need
breakthrough among
along one of these directions to really
build large scale quantum processors
that's you know i'm
i'm you know
yeah
convinced about this
but i think also every challenge is an
opportunity i think this is a very very
special time we can really explore these
things
that's what's very very special
great thanks um thanks misha so i think
we are we are getting close to the
end of our time so maybe uh if there are
any other
comments on the panel if uh
maybe i can just ask a question that
kind of i suspect marcus monica misha
and i both have or all have for umesh
and andrew
so there's been this discussion i think
come up throughout the panel about the
possibility of you know thinking about
dynamics and then after you do some
dynamics measuring some correlation
functions and the possibility that you
know that is really hard
is there you know you know we've heard
examples of you know things where
there's you know provable you know
quantum advantage underlying some of
these you know important sampling type
questions
but at the same time you know as misha
and marcus and monica emphasize i do
think that you know quantum dynamics is
a place where these systems truly shine
i'm wondering whether or not is there
some prospect for the ability to sort of
you know harness some of these
correlation function measurements or
susceptibility measurements you know in
kind of a sharp advantage way or is it
really that you know everything that one
does dynamics measure cool stuff can
never be considered something you know
that will be provably quantum advantage
maybe a naive question sorry
um
do you want to take it or shall i ask
well i mean i think you know
yeah maybe i can say something and but
um i mean i you know i think generally
speaking you know once you can sort of
uh run quantum dynamics i mean you're
gonna run into problems that are sort of
have the full power of quantum computing
in them you'll get sort of bqb hard
problems right so i think you know
already just measuring local observables
you know you don't need to even go to
sort of correlation functions you know
already just measuring local observables
of of sort of you know um
uh all but sort of the simplest quantum
dynamics will will be you know will be a
b q b hard problem so
so in that sense i mean when you say
provably hard i mean of course we don't
know how to prove that you know quantum
computers can you know can't generically
be simulated classically but sort of
that would be the only thing keeping us
from from knowing that those kinds of
problems are hard i would think
does that sound reasonable
maybe what i think maybe i can amplify a
little bit norm's kind of idea so and
for example like
so we know that contracting like 2d peps
i know it's hard you know
can this be used as a basis to really
make you know some
some
sharper statements but perhaps this
could also inspire better understanding
of that maybe can inspire new quantum
algorithms actually
to be implemented so maybe that's maybe
that's where sort of one way to think
about it no it's a question
so maybe if i can take a shot at it so
it seems to me there are two two
different ways to look at it right so
one is can we show quantum advantage in
the sense of saying
um
here's something that you can you can
actually accomplish which
for which there's a there's some some
level of proof that you can't accomplish
it classically and that i you know that
i believe um
uh
you know should be possible and so you
know we'd have to look at these the
specific capability you know
um adap adapt those schemes to this uh
to what can be done
easily in this in this particular
platform
but then
there's a there's a different question
whether whether you can get an advantage
on something useful
right and that that may be the other
thing to think about and and there again
i think there there are two different
ways you can look at it right is it is
it useful computationally and that's
that's something that we'd like to get
to eventually
but
in the in the meantime you know
i mean i i think that there's another
question you could ask in terms of the
dynamics which is
what would it mean to to be able to
simulate the dynamics which is useful
not not necessarily from a computational
viewpoint per se as a as a well-defined
computational problem but from
you know but from a science viewpoint
which is which is what i think misha was
was was uh was getting at right so
so um
i mean i you know it seems to me there
was there were there was some
idea that yes there's a
you know there's there's a
there's uh
there's an advantage to be had in terms
of something useful in the sense of
scientific discovery
and is is there a way to
sort of spell that out even more and say
okay here here's what you can get at
with dynamics that you couldn't get out
with stable states and
you know
basically to quantify the scientific
discount
yeah well or or just intuitively you
know sort of say well you know once
one's digging in this direction because
one expects to find
these kinds of things you know that
that's the
yeah i mean it's often
that the kind of issue maybe what i
would kind of like to
sort of in along these
lines one challenge or maybe it's not
it's both challenges and an opportunity
it's such that you know once you wait in
this kind of dynamics problems
often once you sort of know what to
expect
can often be very you know creative and
clever to come up with the good way to
describe it you know if you don't know
what to expect i mean you're basically
lost in this huge hilbert space right
um but you know for instance one of
these quenches we discovered is revivals
this quantum many body scars you know
once you know that they are there you of
course could try to you know build a
clever you know kind of matrix product
or neck and the network state and you
can you know test if it works but if you
did not know that you know you wouldn't
you know you would never you know never
do it you know is it kind of
is it sort of quantum advantage here on
one hand yes on one hand kind of you
know
not necessarily in terms of computation
but i think for science it is an
advantage right so yeah and um you know
and i think we i think we just need more
examples of this type when we need more
ways to think about
to to figure out how to think about you
know
these things and you know it could be
that kind of in a near term
the most exciting science would be new
insights how to build bigger and better
quantum machines right which is not too
bad also right so you know
great
but thank you thanks uh on that note uh
thanks a lot misha for a
wonderful talk and and thanks um
andrew monica norm and marcus for
uh great discussion
and thank you nash for organizing this
role yeah thank you
thanks very much
great watch you all next week yeah
thank you take care